i like to encourage directors
to be vulnerable around actors
and to
to be able to say to them look
you know something's off here
and i don't know what it is
are the biggest misconceptions people
have about actors that they're too
sensitive that their antenna is always
up that they're constantly watching
themselves in the mirror walk
you know almost as a character walking
into a scene
well i think for directors the directors
that i meet and i you know i taught
workshops for directors for many years
and now i
do sometime i do some consulting with uh
directors getting
preparing to
make a a project and
i think
i think the biggest
misconception
is that
that they're fragile somehow
that uh
that you can't dare talk to them because
they'll go into
so they'll start crying or go into a
rage or or
or or get upset if they're
uh if you say anything about about their
about their work
and
i suppose where this comes from is that
actors do tend to be more expressive
than
actors sort of tend to call them
civilians people who are not actors tend
to be in that world of actors civilians
so actors are more expressive
um and they might they might cry if you
tell them that uh
the last take they were overacting a bit
but they get over it
they're more they're comfortable with
feelings and
the way i see it
the misconception on the part of people
who are not actors that actors are you
know
too
too excitable to uh
too
agitated too quickly um
is
that
in in real life we're not allowed to do
that i think anybody would do that if
they could and um
we're we're conditioned out of it
children
respond whatever they feel they express
right they feel they they're hurt they
cry they're angry they scream
and then little by little we condition
them so they'll be in society we say use
your words
and we're we're
when we tell and i'm not saying we
shouldn't do this but when we tell
children use your words instead of
acting out your feelings we're asking
them to intellectualize their feelings
and that's the process of society is
intellectualizing our feelings so that
people can get along and everybody can
you know get to work every day and
and uh
you know not
scream at each other when um
on although of course that's happening
more than people screaming at each other
so strange
but uh reverting to that uh kind of
childish behavior but but uh so it's
good if people don't revert to their
childish behavior in the form of road
rage
but um
but for actors it's part of a craft it's
you know let being available to their
feelings being able to
uh
cry or or stomp their feet
is is part of their craft
and um i think i think sometimes
directors take it personally they think
oh they hate me you know oh they're
they're they're fragile but actors
aren't that fragile they really like to
be told uh we were talking earlier about
you know if you have lipstick on your
teeth or something they really want to
know that
it shouldn't be awkward at all to tell
an actor that there's lipstick on their
teeth that uh because they don't want to
be photographed with lipstick on their
teeth
so they're grateful if someone tells
them
and uh and and also if they're over
acting i mean it might it might be it
might be upsetting for them to hear that
but in the end they would rather hear
that than be cut out of the movie which
you might have to do in the editing room
if the if the performance isn't good
enough
and so let's suppose
i love that analogy of the lipstick on
the teeth um
i'm doing a scene and you've noticed
that i have lipstick on my teeth you're
you're pulling me aside privately to
tell me this what's the best way
to say you know karen could i talk to
you for a moment well actually the
makeup person should take care of this
ah okay the makeup person should take
care of this but uh
should be watching for this and and
should be running up and uh
and taking care of it
the
but it should be everything should be
private everything should be private if
the makeup person hasn't stepped forward
and you have to say to the makeup person
will you go and take care of there's
makeup on her teeth would you take care
of that
then um
there's no need to announce it to the
crew sure
and when when directors have something
to give direction or to say something
about the take that just happened or
what they want to try in the next one
that should always be private
always be private the act the director
should come up and take the
the uh actor uh away a little bit uh and
privately or whisper whispering is uh is
useful it's never helpful
to give a direction that the rest of the
crew can hear
and the reason for that is that then the
crew is watching
to see if the actor takes that direction
and the actor knows that they're being
watched not just by the director who
hopefully they trust and want to please
but by a whole bunch of people who
who may not know
so much about acting they're watching
being watched by a whole bunch of people
and maybe even gossiped about
uh
so
it's very uh very very helpful
for
an actor's safety
to
to speak to
for the director to speak to the actors
privately always away from away from the
producers away from the
um
crew
and
and it's it's it's a it creates a safety
for the director as well
because
i like to encourage directors
to be vulnerable around actors
and to
to be able to say to them look you know
something's off here
and i don't know what it is
can you tell can you do you have some
ideas about what we might do here
and you don't want to say that in front
of the crew
you want that to be a private
conversation between you and the actor
but i do think it's very very helpful
for directors to be able to
tell an actor when they're
when they
when they're not sure what's wrong
just you know to instead of jumping into
fix-it mode a lot of directors feel like
oh something's wrong i have to fix it
but i want to encourage
a collaboration between
directors and actors
where the um
you know where you draw you you you pick
their brains you you bring them into the
process you
you uh use
their ideas and their
skills
to help you solve problems that you
solve problems together if there are
problems
you had said earlier about um
actors calling uh quote-unquote normies
or whatever civilian civilians right so
not normal so okay so
uh civilians it almost brings me back to
let's say in the workplace if you've
ever worked in an office like a
nine-to-five job and you're quiet and
the just you hear the typing and the
picking up hello and it just it's so
subdued but then if you've ever worked
in a restaurant or the service industry
it's wild and crazy and people are
yelling and that's acceptable in that
world to a degree as long as people are
somewhat professional but it almost
sounds like that's the
the analogy of what we see as as
performers is sort of this bar
environment versus the subdued library
office
where no one raises their voice everyone
speaks in a very calm tone
but is that really true are actors
really that
that they can go there too they can be
you know so actors are all different
actors are all different
and some actors really like to be alone
in between takes and not be sociable
and other actors like to horse around
and
and uh
jabber with their with their fellow
actors um
they're all different they're they're
all they're all different that i mean as
far as the
atmosphere on the set the the director
is responsible for that
you know for creating an atmosphere uh
that
so the atmosphere might be
full of excitement and and uh
kind of a feeling that we're all on edge
and anything can go
great or go wrong at any time and that
could be a very creative atmosphere or
or it can be very workmanlike and that
can be a very creative atmosphere
so
uh
yeah yeah
the director set the tone
ah okay unless they've let that
uh duty slip away from them
to uh you know
to someone else
like a producer or uh
or an actor
you know a lead actor sometimes
will will take over
if there's a vacuum if there's a vacuum
if the director has not
set a tone of what they want to how they
want things to go on a set then there's
a vacuum
someone will probably come in
and it might not go the way you want it
to
and that tone doesn't have to be
verbally set it could be set in
you know
action how they how they work with other
people
well it's part of why directing is a
really hard job
really complex and hard job you've got
to be very very prepared you've got to
have talked to everybody ahead of time
all the crew chiefs so that you're well
they still call it on the same page
and um
so that people so it's actions and words
and and it's so you know your own
demeanor and
and
um uh
yeah
it's like any it's like any supervisor
i think it's you know the manager the
the leadership skills the leadership
skills that you need for any
job that's in a leadership position